I think the fact that you've got the
Russians and the Americans talking about
anything with any degree of success is
pretty impressive and I suppose when you
can't really secure uh World Peace then
at least you can agree on details of a
prisoner exchange this is in fact the
second prisoner Exchange in eight months
we had a fairly high profile prisoner
exchange one for one uh back in April
between a Russian a Russian pilot was
exchanged for a U.S marine who had been
held in prison for not very long here
for assaulting a policeman allegedly um
but Brittany Greiner is the most famous
American detainee because she's a huge
basketball star so her arrest back in
February for allegedly
um coming into Russia with cannabis oil
in Vape cartridges in her hand luggage
um caused a huge stir and we heard
Anthony blinken the U.S Secretary of
State say some say sometime in the
summer that he'd had high level
discussions trying to ensure that both
Brittany and Paul Whelan another U.S
citizen who has been in jail for a long
time here in Russia that the Americans
had made a substantial offer for both of
them but as we see today Brittany
Greiner is on her way back but Paul
Whelan is still in jail it will be his
fourth Christmas away from his family so
hugely disappointing for Paul Whelan's
family I think although a wonderful day
of course for Brittany Greiner and for
Victor boot he is as you say a notorious
arms dealer who was in the 11th year of
a 25-year sentence in the United States
the Russians have wanted him for a long
time he's always the number one name
that comes up when you talk about
prisoner exchanges here and his wife and
daughter in Saint Petersburg will of
course be very pleased that he is coming
home but yes Paul Whelan still in a U.S
jail and his brother sent an email out
today saying of course we don't begrudge
Britney's release welcome home Brittany
you know we're so glad for your family
that you can feel this way but perhaps
the American leadership needs to take
different steps he said for example the
U.S needs a swifter more direct response
may mean taking more law breaking
kremlin-connected Russians into custody
well I I'm not sure that the Americans
are going to do that anytime soon but we
did hear from Joe Biden that he was
absolutely committed to trying to secure
not just Paul Whelan's release but that
also of other Americans unjustly
detained around the world